[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
beyond corp enterprise can secure access
to your services from beyond the
corporate walls
companies are increasingly more
distributed as employees work in more
locations
connecting to a vpn can be slow for
employees located far away from the
headquarters
however granting flat access to internal
apps based only on the network can also
be dangerous with a network-centric
model attackers can exfiltrate data just
by gaining access to the network to
solve these problems beyond corp
enterprise pushes security checks from
the network back to the user's device
and context
it does this by creating a proxy in
front of apps running in gcp other cloud
platforms or on-premises
the proxy passes through or blocks
traffic based on the requester's device
information their identity and hundreds
of other signals
for example you can choose to allow
access to hr apps only for devices
managed by the company for added
security you can enforce multi-factor
authentication as well
to secure hr apps using access context
manager define an access level
this level includes requests from
devices managed by the company and
requests authenticated with multi-factor
next using identity aware proxy map the
new access level to the hr web app
so next time you're looking to shift to
a zero trust context-diverse security
model take a minute to look at beyond
forb enterprise
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
beyondcorp enterprise